thank you very much for coming to my
talk i'm really honored by your presence
today i'm going to be talking about
immunology and to motivate an interest
in immunology let's think about vaccines
so vaccines came in 1976 with edward
jenner
1796. thank you
uh so this is quite a while ago uh i
mean when you think about science in
1796 it was not quite at the level that
we
have today so you it's natural to ask
where are we
200 years later
so one thing is we certainly know a lot
more about immunology
a lot more but this hasn't really
changed our fundamental approach to
developing vaccines
so we might see that by a recent hiv
trial
there that first recruited 26 000
volunteers
and then there were 16 000 that made it
through the initial screening
criteria and then the 16 000 were
randomized into on one hand a placebo
arm and on the other
a vaccine arm and
the study was run for six years and out
of that
125 infections were observed so let's
let's leave aside the moral issues of
such a trial
for a second and just think about the
fact that
a trial that costs 105 million divided
by
125 is a very expensive statistical
experiment
and this is not really a good way to go
ahead
and develop better vaccines we would
like to to leverage what we know about
immunology in order to inform our
vaccine
design so the
one of the questions that i'm really
interested in is how might we guide
vaccine
development without disease exposure
because disease exposure is
complicated and and time consuming and
morally
ambiguous questionable
so in zooming in a little bit we're
going to be talking about the
the b cell response sometimes called the
humeral
response it's the response that is
mediated by antibodies
so uh uh so let's subset our thoughts a
little bit to what can we learn from b
cells without battle testing them
without actually exposing them to the
pathogen that they should be able to
block
some quick biological background so
this is a cartoon of an antibody it's
formed of two
identical parts this side and this side
uh and it's and each part is formed of a
heavy chain
and a light chain and it has
each one of these chains has basically a
hand that reaches out and binds the
antigen
so the antigen is just whatever molecule
that's associated with a pathogen
that an antibody wants to recognize so
we have one hand here and one hand here
is that clear okay so this is the slide
my wife calls the too many underpants
slide
but seriously there's so many antigens
they take all sorts of shapes and sizes
and there's no way that given this
diversity
of antibodies that your genome could
code for each
antigen individually so the body has
developed this incredibly
elaborate and interesting process which
actually came
about the time that we got jaws so
lampreys don't have this but
most of the things you usually think of
as animals have this uh and it's
separated into two parts there's this
rearrangement phase and an affinity
maturation phase
so first the the rearrangement phase so
there's
lots of different v genes lots of
different d
genes and lots of different j genes and
in order to make
a b cell receptor which is the
the locus that determines the shape of
an antibody
there's a random choice of a v gene a
random choice of a d gene and a random
choice of a j
gene these are deleted to some extent so
that's what this is supposed to show
and then they're joined together using
these non-templated insertions
so they're called non-templated
insertions because this part
on the other hand is is more of a
germ line it is coded for in your
in your genome whereas this to first
approximation is sort of just
random incorporation of nucleotides
so i'll be calling this the germline
these the germline regions and this the
non-templated insertion regions
and so i'll have a little cartoon here
this is a cell this is showing the
genome of the cell
it's the genotype which comes from that
and then the phenotype which is what is
the antibody that expresses
peter does this get translated
does this get translated yeah yeah so we
translate this
along with some other things and it
makes this
so you're thinking about frame maybe
well
we'll talk about frame uh okay so
that the end of that process gives us
this
this is called a naive b cell and then
there's this process of somatic
hypermutation and affinity maturation so
if we have an
antigen like this we want uh
the body is trying to increase its
affinity for this antigen and it does so
by a process of
mutation and sometimes these mutations
make it bind worse
such as this one or maybe they may find
they make it mine better like this cup
fits this antigen pretty well and
eventually it fits really well and then
it reproduces like crazy
so again this process is called affinity
maturation so this is when i get excited
because
this is a process of mutation and
selection
and we know something about these so now
i can actually
outline what it is that i'm going to
talk about
i'm going to talk about two subjects
within two large goals that we have
within the group
so one is to
recapitulate the actual immune
repertoire
by doing sequencing so what this is a
diagram of is
each one of these comes from an
independent rearrangement event
i've only shown three here but in
reality there's millions
and then each one of these can undergo
some
affinity maturation process so we can
take a blood sample
and sequence basically exactly what we
see here and we'd like to be able to
reconstruct
this immune history is that clear
all right
so what we're going to be talking about
today
is just if we want to do
likelihood-based inference
in this framework we're need going to
need to have
mutation models for how somatic
hypermutation happens
i should say substitution models so
we're going to be looking at those
and then another big goal which is sort
of crazily ambitious
is understand how we might manipulate
the immune repertoire with interventions
and part of that is if we take this this
is what an antibody really looks like
at least in a cartoon and we
we want to improve its affinity for
something that we care about
what sites should we change
so that's obviously a difficult problem
but it and
an aspect of that is what sites can we
change
so you we're going to be looking at
natural selection inference on these
antibodies
as a way of understanding if we did want
to change things about these antibodies
what
what might we be allowed to change
our data is going to be sequences from
the cdr3 locus so
remember i was talking about the two
hands each hand is composed of three
fingers these complementarity
determining regions
and we're going to be sequencing this
finger the cdr3 which is highly variable
and we're going to start our sequencing
region about here go through the cdr3
and then back into what's called the
framework region
the framework region is is what gives it
a little bit more structure
is this is it very different from the
cdr ones here too
it's a natural one to pick because it's
highly diverse and it's
heavily involved in the it's it's a very
big finger
yeah well i mean they're also important
and it can
like everything in biology it varies
greatly but cdr3 on average is quite an
important one
yeah correspond to that
the linear representation yeah so this
this section here is this section here
so we're just sequencing this little
loop but that little loop
is not so little uh it involves this v d
and j recombination with non-template
insertion with it
so you're absolutely right this is a
small part of a big antibody
and ideally we would love to sequence
the whole antibody people do
with 454 but we wanted to use illumina
to get a very deep
survey so this is 5 million
sequences per individual that we have
three individuals 130 nucleotides for
each
and there's a reason why we want to do
it so deeply it's not just because we
want to rev our engines
it's uh like this is an incredibly
diverse repertoire even with this level
of sequencing we have
we're just sort of scratching the
surface of the diversity of the b-cell
repertoire
let's see okay so this first part
you have you're enriching for some
concert
bit that's right on the edge and then
this is a this is an awesome question so
that so sequencing is sort of
repeat oh sorry um the question
is uh are we enriching for are we
amplifying and then sequencing and the
answer is absolutely yes
and sequencing has really only come to
this game a little bit late
and there's a reason for that because if
you want to do this sort of sequencing
you have to deal with the fact that
there's lots of different variability
there's not only variable in terms of vd
and j but there's also somatic hypomutat
which makes it difficult to uniformly
amplify the repertoire
so the our collaborator on this harlem
robbins has worked very very hard to
ensure that the primers that they use
amplify everything that you have well i
mean amplify everything
where everything has a star on it
meaning not everything but
but i mean uh but you know they've
worked very hard in this problem
um but it's not trivial and so that's
why sequencing
like high throughput sequencing of the
immune repertoire really started in 2009
and
has sort of gone on since then
okay so uh substitution models for
affinity maturation so i'll be showing
some matrices that are like this where
light color
means a fast rate and a darker color
means a slow rate
so this is the rate of substitution from
an a
say to a t and so on
just to motivate the next part i should
say that
although there are big expansions of an
individual rearrangement
on average these are small compared to
the overall size of the repertoire
there are so many rearrangements out
there that if we uniformly select
two somatically hypermutated
sequences on average they won't have a
common ancestor
the probability they have a common
ancestor will be small
there's exceptions for instance when
someone has cancer us an individual b
cell will expand to
absolutely dominate the population but
that's that's not common in normal
people
so for that reason we are
going to be ignoring the actual
phylogenetic structure of
these sequences as they're mutating and
just treat them as
two tax on trees so the way it works is
we're going to take
our sequence divide it up into parts
that we think are coming from the v
d and j segment take that say the v
section find the best matching v in the
genome
corresponds to that and then we're going
to make a little two taxon tree
so where we know the ancestral state and
then
we're finding the derived and then we
observe the derived state and we're
going to be looking at this mutation
process
we're going to be doing that for v's d's
and j's
is that clear okay so
again we have 15 million three tax on
well triplets of two tax entries
so we're going to be testing models so
the first question is
uh do we need to have a different model
for the different segments
so here i've sort of cartoon-wise shown
the vd and j-models
this is the simplest possible model
where they have the same mutation rate
matrix between the segments
and they also have the same branch
length so we're allowing the same number
of
substitutions for all three segments
and but of course we have different
branch links for the different sequences
a slightly more complex model is one
where we enforce the same mutation model
but we have just a global multiplier of
the d
rate as compared to the v rate so this d
rate
is this multiplier times
the v i shouldn't say rate i should say
branch length so the branch length here
is this
d rate times the branch length of v and
this one we have a similar situation
with j
so j the branch length for j
is a multiplier of the v
a more complex small is where we allow
different mutation matrices
for the different segments
is this the way you think you want to
make it most complicated
first time because there's also probably
local context dependence of the
mutation there is local context
dependence
so for this talk i'm really just looking
at the single nucleotide
mutation process blinding myself to the
fact that there are context specific
mutations but
they come in a little bit later and so
and then maybe there's also variation
like within a region as you
go towards the edges or i don't know
maybe there isn't
uh well i mean our the data somehow is a
little bit short to really
differentiate these things but we will
be looking at sort of
rather than these uh segment specific
things we'll be looking at per
residue a little bit later but this
you're saying like if you look at the
data these differences kind of jump
out and you'll see that they are
actually different yeah and
is this before after selection on these
so you're sort of switching between
mutations
i'm sorry every time when i say mutation
i should say
uh substitution so this is a
substitution model
okay so active selections act exactly
okay
yeah these are people you can't put them
in a germ-free
room for their entire lives yeah there's
many things we would like to do
right uh but we can do some of those
things tonight
so yeah and then a most complex model
would be one where there's
a separate branch length for each one of
these
segments and just if we run aic and bic
we get this model that has a multiplier
it has a different
mutation substitution rate matrix for
each segment
and we reject the the more simple and
more complex models
so this i mean
this is going to be a theme we saw the
identical results
between individuals and we also saw aic
and dsc ranking them
identically so it seems fairly clear
that we want a model that looks like
this
i can't tell which of your models that
is that has this is the one that has the
has a it's different matrices and then a
multi
one multiplier for each segment no it's
clear i was looking at the
line segments but i should have been
looking at two questions
okay so let's look at the what we infer
to be
wow the branch length
so what we have here is just a histogram
of the branch length and also the
inferred values for these multipliers
so this for this individual we infer
that the d is the wall is substituting
at about three times
the v h at point six
and for this individual we see a
non-zero mode
so this individual on average had some
substitution and just to remind you
these are branch lengths in terms of
number of substitutions per site
it's not exactly this but you can think
of this point as being about 10
mutated so
there's uh definitely some mutation
not a wild amount of mutation uh
except for if you're looking at broadly
neutralizing antibodies as
she talked about and i mean that like
those are way out here
like i don't even know i mean maybe
they're way over here they're
they're very far out in the distribution
so we can
similarly look at different um the
different individuals
here this one had about a multiplier of
about four
but still 0.6 about for the j rate and
similarly about four
and about 0.6 so the sequences that
you're looking at
are they are these individuals they
don't have like an acute infection or is
it
sorry it's hiv and over i'm sorry these
these are healthy individuals this is
like you went in and we drew your blood
and
it's a single time at a single time plan
signed a single time point so this is
this is across
the different regions
yeah we yeah we would like to know that
information
that this is 0.4 substitutions per site
like since the
ancestor exactly do you have an idea of
how many b-cell generations that is
that's a complicated question i mean
that that is an active
research question in immunology whether
uh these things like yeah exactly how
that works
i'd like to know that i mean you expect
it to be very spiky substitution
right right i mean something gets
triggered and then
it goes through this hyper mutation
and then maybe doesn't mutate for a long
time afterwards well we're looking at
the substitution process as it
happens in an individual and and how
exactly the cellular dynamics of that
work are
i don't think we can quite reason about
without knowing more about it enough
could you go boy maybe i should just say
i hope these are clarifying questions
so i'm just curious and you said the
alignments were sort of did
you you determined where the borders for
uh bd
and jay were not purely somehow but in
terms of the alignments like
sometimes if you have poor alignment
that can give a false signature for
positive selection and i was wondering
um if the elevated rate for d is because
we don't do a very good job i mean
certainly you're going to have a sum
proportion
like this but i'm just wondering like
maybe it's so high if is d the smallest
region for instance or is the
yeah these are the shortest and it gets
eroded the most because it's yeah it's a
word on both sides okay
so you're right um but i don't think
that this is just an online artifact
yeah
so why don't we give eric the next 20
minutes to talk
yeah this is great well i mean it's just
up to you
well i mean you're talking about
continuing
uh okay so
uh if we if we look at the
the v d and j rate matrices
between individuals we see what i think
is
quite surprising and interesting that
there's a real consistency between
individuals so these columns look
similar to one other but the rows look
rather different to one another
in particular j seems to have a
different evolutionary
substitution process than the others
we can just plot this by setting up the
matrices
such that this point represents uh
what the entry was in the individual a
and what this
and then this one the same entry but in
the individual b
and just do that for all pairs and we
can see that these line up nicely along
y is equal to the x line
so this is an important aside that
we actually have two subpopulations of
these
sequences one
we can see is in frame so by in frame i
mean that the
v is in the same frame
as the j
and that will make a happy antibody on
the other hand
if if this frame is different than this
frame it won't
right because uh if this one's in frame
then maybe we'll prob we'll get a bunch
of stop codons here and that won't make
a proper antibody
so for a biological reason that i won't
describe that it's very interesting
um we we get to sequence
both these and these we these are a
little bit more rare than we get to see
these
but we get to see them both and what
we're going to use later about these
these sequences is that they undergo a
neutral mutation process
so no like no selection happening on
these guys
because they don't make any real
antibody
and these ones do make a real antibody
and there's very strong selection
i'll i'll entertain one question if
people want to clarify this point
because it's important
great uh okay so we're going to stratify
a bunch of sequences first so we're just
going to substitute the v
region and we're going to look at the a
individuals a b and c separately we're
going to look at the genes separately
and we're going to separate by
productive and unproductive status
so this is basically watch out
okay this is basically what we get
when we take each of these matrices
and project it down in in by principal
components so
this is i i i won't describe exactly how
we do this but i will acknowledge that
it's not completely trivial to do
principal components on
these sorts of rate matrices but i think
we've done the right thing
so each point here represents a rate
matrix so this is a picture of
how the different segments
are evolving how the different genes and
so on are evolving how that
influences the evolutionary patterns
that we see
so we can see that the the most
important difference
along this first principle component is
is the outer frame sequences
appear to be different than the in-frame
sequences these productive sequences
so that's not too surprising really so
you get one
matrix for each sequence uh it's
for each gene so i shouldn't say
sequence i should say for each
so we're taking the sequences we
partition them first by individual
and then by gene and then by productive
and unproductive and
we fit rate matrices to each one of
these bends thank you
okay so there's a clear signal in terms
of
in and out of frame
there doesn't appear to be an individual
level signal
which doesn't surprise me too much given
the similarity between individuals on
the previous
uh and there is a signal in terms of
gene subgroups so the
the v genes get classified into seven
groups
and it does appear that there's some
clustering here these magenta ones are
different than these brown ones and so
on
okay
so we can also look at the branch length
distributions
very briefly we can just see that
this this green one which is the
unproductive sequences have sort of a
fatter tail
meaning there are some sequences that
are very highly mutated
and then it also has a higher peak at
zero meaning that there are
sequences that don't get mutated very
much so we can
this sort of makes sense there's no
evolutionary constraint on these
sequences over here right
uh so we can see them accumulating more
mutations
this i don't know if i can really
explain so there's sort of more
sequences
that are unproductive that don't get
mutated at all
so i'll skip the wrap up
so our second goal again is trying to
understand if we can mutate specific
residues
and we're going to be doing a selection
analysis for that
so uh as many of you probably know
we can divide mutations into synonymous
mutations that preserve the amino acid
that is coded for and they can and we
can say
look at non-synonymous mutations that
change the underlying amino acid and
this is going to
form the the underlying structure that
we use
to infer selection so
we're going to be looking at omega or
dnds so which is the rate of
non-substitution divided by the rate of
synonymous substitution so i want to
emphasize
that this is not the number of
synonymous
non-synonymous divided by the number of
synonymous it's a rate in terms of some
background process and that background
process is going to be very important
for us to understand
in this setting so higher dnds means
diversifying selection
such as these guys out here and and
lower
means like this so this is sort of a
foreshadow of what we're hoping to get
um maybe i've taken away the suspense by
showing you that we actually got it
but there's challenges with this so one
is there's a strange mutational process
that daniel already sort of mentioned
there's this context dependence perhaps
and there's a lot of sequences so
there's been some really great work by
ben morrell and company that has
extended
dnds type analysis to thousands of
sequences but we
have a few more than that uh so
this is a picture of the strange
mutational process that i'm talking
about
so what we have these are only
out-of-frame sequences and we're looking
just at the synonymous rate
and the the colors are these individuals
so we can see this consistently
varying sub uh synonymous substitution
rate so this site
in all three individuals was very
mutated and this site was not
so these are very close sites together
yeah is it a logarithmic scale
yes this is a logarithmic scale
uh so we're gonna use so
the fact that this is not just
completely stochastic is wonderful for
us
we have this sort of reliable estimate
of the
neutral mutation process that we can use
for
our dnds analysis so in particular we're
going to be
just defining omega like this we're
going to be taking
the rate in the non-synonymous the
non-synonymous rate
in the in-frame sequences and
normalizing it
by the non-synonymous rate in the outer
frame sequences
so this should take care of that
bouncing back and forth and we'll do the
similar thing for
the synonymous rate
uh so this is still a lot of sequences
to do this sort of thing with
and we are employing this thing called
renaissance accounting which is quite a
clever strategy which works as follows
so typically the way that these
inference procedures work is you fit an
entire codon model
and that's great but it's sort of too
hard for us there's
we have too much data so instead what we
can do is we
sample mutation histories as they go
back
in time uh using just a single
nucleotide
mutation model and then we treat these
as observed
and then because they're observed we can
just count the number of mutations of
different types we can say this
is a synonymous mutation and this one is
a non-synonymous mutation because we
we've basically imputed in a
probabilistic sense
what these different internal sequences
are i'll take a question
okay but we don't we of course we don't
pretend that we actually know them
but we just uh sample them uh according
to our posterior probability and then
it also comes out in the wash
so these estimates can be unstable so we
need to do
an empirical base regularization which
i'll explain using a metaphor of a
smoking survey so
say we're interested in doing a smoking
survey in a state
and the survey works by sending people
into the state and seeing how many
people
on the street are smoking so they go
into a certain state and they don't
observe any people smoking
that doesn't mean that there's actually
no people smoking in that county it just
means that we happen not to see any when
we did this survey
so what we're going to do is use all the
data to fit a prior distribution
of the frequency of smoking overall in
the state and then we're going to
take a posterior distribution using
these observations
so this is what it looks like for us
the model is that we assume that these
mutation
rates come from a gamma with two
parameters a and b
or alpha and beta and then
uh we draw substitution counts
as being poisson from these and
if you know your conjugate priors and
such
you'll recognize that then this
posterior is going to look something
like this
but the key is the alpha and beta are
fit to all the data thank you
alpha and beta fit to all the data so
this is sort of like the equivalent
of the overall prevalence of smoking and
then we see a thing that's
an individual county and then we sort of
turn all of that information into a
posterior distribution that we can draw
from
so and then we plug it into this formula
and this is going to give us a posterior
on omega
so that's what i'm about to show oh it
it still takes a lot of computation so
each individual
took uh three days on a quite a big ec2
instance
using spark okay so
this is uh so we we get this
for each v gene individually but we can
collect these together and and look at
an overall
v selection map so what we're looking at
is position by
position uh what is the distribution of
the omegas that we have observed so
again down here is going to be
purifying selection and up here is
diversifying selection
uh so these are violin density plots
which are sort of just density plots
that are on the side so
so this means uh that you know the the
median of all of the inferences for the
v genes
is somewhere up up there like 0.2 we can
also classify the sites as being
purifying or diversifying based on
whether they the 95
confidence interval excludes one so
that's what we get down here
so the this means that uh 90
or you know some percentage of the genes
were classified as being purifying under
purifying selection
and then this is the amount under
diversifying selection
this is uh the positions along the v so
remember we were doing the sequencing
and we had this
loop and it was going from sort of red
to yellow
so the yellow was the framework region
and then the uh the red was
this variable loop so that's exactly
what we have here
so we're going this is framework
at least it's called framework and then
this is the variable region we can see
that there's an enrichment
for the for purifying selection
sorry for less purifying selection
as we go into the variable loop which is
not terribly surprising
i just want to point out this which i
found quite interesting
so this is a fixed cysteine this is
crucial
for the functioning of the antibody
however there's this site that's uh
two back that has really strong
purifying selection
and i i didn't know anything about this
and uh none of the immunologist
people that i talked to knew about it
either
so i'll be interested in that
like the others we can see that this is
quite consistent between individuals
which i also find quite interesting i
mean these people have uncorrelated
immune history at least presumably
we see sort of this bump and then some
sub bumps and we see the same pattern of
a bump and
sub bumps in in similar locations
so this is just saying that we make a
plot
they appear to line up along the line so
my question was what is going on
with that site 102
uh so what this plot is showing is
is the distribution of amino acids in
terms of just fraction
so to the left of the line is in the
outer frame sentences
and the right is the in-frame sequences
so these are the ones that
should not be experiencing selection and
these ones are the ones that are
experiencing selection
so we can see that there's sort of if we
look at 102 there's sort of a commission
of different
amino acids in the unselected population
but
once selection acts we have a
phenylalanine and a tyrosine
and these are both aromatic amino acids
and so
i don't have a slide for this but we
went back and mapped these onto the
structure
and this is clearly a
an amino acid that is stabilizing the
structure of the
of the immunoglobulin or antibody and so
it can only tolerate a change to another
aromatic amino acid
and in fact we see a number of aromatic
amino acids coming along here
that's the the frequency
i'm sorry i love zooming in on slides
but sometimes it's not good so
uh so what this plot is showing is how
frequent
was a v
in the outer frame versus in the in
frame
okay um
you guys will have a chance to ask
questions because
i'm just wrapping up so um
the we developed the selection inference
procedure and and
we can you know one can use this
selection inference procedure any time
you have
data i mean it would be i guess
interesting for people who have
lots of data and i should say i guess i
didn't say this before but
this regularization existed before but
we extended it to the case where
you have non-constant coverage of the
site so originally
so we could have used the previous
technology by basically just
trimming everything to the shortest read
and then treating that
doing empirical based regularization on
that but we extend it to the case where
you have a varying amount of coverage
across your team we use this to derive
it for residue selection map
something i didn't i guess really
emphasized before but i think it's quite
impressive
that of all the genes that we should
care about
uh we should have a lot of diversifying
selection but
but we see quite a lot of purifying
selection happening here but it's
it's not constant and it's consistent
between individuals which i find can be
quite interesting
um yeah there's a sort of amino acid
story so the paper is up on archive
uh and with that i would like to thank
my king collaborators which were really
fantastic
this is a true group effort between
connor
trevor and vladimir and myself and
harlan
brought the data and some great
biological expertise
thank paul lindow for actually doing the
work
he's these funding agencies and if it
may take a second just to say that we
have
one or two postdocs opening up and
if you know anyone who's interested in
molecular evolution apply to the real
world
health context please have them contact
me thank you
so my understanding is that to do the
selection analysis we need to
first classify b d and j into the sub
lineages
um so you for us
yeah and so um
my concern about that is that
uh so i don't know what tool you guys
use for that
well i'd say it depends less on the tool
and we're on the parameter routine so
here so so first of all the selection
analysis was just done for me
but we need to match it to its ancestral
state you're right and that is not a
perfect
well it's not just not for it's like 75
percent accuracy
it's not high so we did some simulations
that
indicated that it wasn't as that bad but
we also did something where we
just took the sequences that were very
confidently classified and we saw
qualitatively similar results
so that's a good question
in the first part of your talk when you
said you looked at b d and j separately
isn't d really short region so how do
you identify the drum line
with the d well sometimes we can
so in general you can actually fire well
i mean that is the most uncertain
so maybe the previous question applies i
mean we looked at situations where we
could identify quite confidently and saw
that we saw similar results
so wait before you go again maybe
something else
so i was wondering about this with some
in frame announcer frame
models and it seems like the ones which
are out of grave must have been in frame
for some number of the substitutions has
occurred
and so can you actually find dates how
long they stayed in phone call
okay so i didn't take the time to
explain this but i think this is quite
an interesting process that i
actually want you to work on um
that uh
so we we are a diploid organism
therefore we have two copies of these
lost signs
and the way it works apparently is there
you have you
are b cell and you haven't rearranged
yet
you try first with one copy
to rearrange if that's successful you
stop and you go party
uh if you're unsuccessful then you get
the second
chance if you fail the second chance you
get thrown away
so the sequences that we're sequencing
that are out of frame are presumably
just carried along by a successful
rearrangement in the other locus
and the reason why we think we can
classify them confidently according to
in-frame versus out-of-frame is because
somatic hypermutation is primarily a
point mutation process
and we saw that too in our data we saw a
very high proportion of presentations
i mean it's sort of like you know
very a fraction of a percent of of
intel's
when we looked at things that we know
knew the ancestors
does that answer your question all right
okay um
so i understand that you're using the
omega from your out of frame
to kind of normalize it well the
substitution rate not the omega but yes
the lambda
same three individuals you have sort of
the sites where you have
actually uh dnds much greater than one
right so so i'm wondering um
uh rather than just kind of using those
i'm wondering whether you have any kind
of insight into
why you actually see that in these out
of three
so why do we see the like this
non-constant synonymous rate in the
out-of-brain sequences yeah right
exactly so
this is something we are working on
quite actively um
so the
the stock immunology answer is that
these are context specific mutations and
because these v
genes have similar contexts
so what i mean by context specific i
mean that they depend on the
more than just the mutation the the
nucleotide that's observed but also the
ones that surround it
um then we would that would give us this
pattern
um it's possible there's more to that
story we're sort of trying to start
like start fresh and understand like
if we just take a sort of statistical
approach and try to think about what are
the best models to use to fit this does
it
fall out of that but i should say it's
quite amazing so another interest of
ours
are these apobac families of proteins
that mutate retroviruses
and it turns out we were working that
and then we started working on this and
it turns out that the apobac
proteins are a close relative of
the of the proteins that do this
so it's sort of one part of the family
defends us against retroviruses and the
other mutates our genome so that we can
fight off viruses and other things
better okay
speakers